roma ville les rues et le ciel des
banlieues d'ici trente gosses sont
partis il ya dix jours pour la montagne
et le soleil pour l' aventure des
classes de neige
c'est une expérience en plein essor le
principe on le connaît école le matin
skis l'après midi il en coûte aux
parents de 150 francs par jour à l'école
henri-barbusse à romainville
ce sont des garçons du cours moyen
première année qui ont été choisis par
le directeur pour le deuxième départ de
la saison
toute la classe sauf ceux ci jean alors
pourquoi toi tu n'y vas pas et tu sais
pourquoi ne peux pas c'est parce que el
maleh jamais laissé partir tout seul
non pas parce que j'ai une hernie
travaux foccart et lacoste haut d'un
mois c'est à cause de mon fois qu'elle
fragile parce que on est sûrs de la
cantine ça y est se sont retrouvés garde
lyon le 21 février 9h du soir avec armes
et bagages
accompagné du professeur de gymnastique
de l'assistante sociale et de
mademoiselle faivre l'institutrice qui
seront leurs mentors pendant un mois
le gros des équipements anorak fuseau
souliers de ce qui a été fourni par la
municipalité et les familles selon les
possibilités de chaque foyer
quant au ski ils les trouveront là haut
demain sur place
alors qui c'est le plus fort en classe
vous êtes tous est plus fort et la
maîtresse a déjanté
oui la nuit venait ils se sont installés
comme ils ont pu sur les banques est une
jambe par ci une tête par là
le matin au réveil il y a eu un grand
silence n'est aux fenêtres il regardait
alors c'est comment quand on arrive à la
montagne paru hier
[Musique]
jarville jean laville coeur bien aller
vieux lieu qu'est ce qui est bien mieux
et qui respire mieux et il enseigne au
dessus de gars dans la montagne
voilà le cadre de leur vie pour un mois
ils vont apprendre ce que c'est que nous
glissement d'un paquet des neiges sur un
toit la re classe les attend ici dans
l'ancienne école libre du pays devant la
porte à un bonhomme de neige en signe de
bienvenue
on a allumé le poil depuis 6 heures ce
matin et astiquer les vieilles tables à
l'hôtel où nous avons trouvé monsieur
demande le patron en train de s'occuper
des anciens du pays pourquoi que la
maladroite et que monsieur nouveau c'est
intéressant pour un hôtelier les classes
de neige les partenaires elle vient
faire cet intéressant
pourquoi mais pourquoi parce qu'on a
permis d créé ici une petite et station
c'est place des langues
ça vous permet d'occuper du personnel ça
n'a été vu depuis ça me permet d'occuper
le personnel du pays que l'hiver et ne
travaille pas ailleurs alors là ils
peuvent me donner un coup de main ils
font d'ailleurs très volontiers quand il
voyait courir tous ces petits la peine
de la neige douce à l'échelle du pays
cévenol
[Musique]
première leçon de ski le jour même de
l'arrivée
regardez mes et regretter de ne plus
avoir 10 ans les bleus se servait bien
oui un petit peu j'étais reçues le jet
au nom jeu trop petit
j'avais fumé non ton compte quoi optech
avec mon père eu une bouffée est encore
attendue dimanche jamais d'alcool je
fais ou jamais non c'est des sports de
stiller ou ne validait pas de vacances
vous savez que ça va je suis pas fier de
moi fier qu'on ait menacé le bouton
parce que ma mère est là
ma mère elle en avait pas de vacance
tasty mon père m'ont plu et puis c'est
pour ça qu'ils disent qu'on a de la
chance me d'avril consensus
c'est un avis de ses ennuis ce qu on a
quand même de la chance tu regrettes
pour des parents qu'ils n'avaient pas eu
oui je regrette parce que ils n'ont pas
eu de chance au il paraît que depuis que
vous savez que vous allez partir en
classe de neige
c'est vrai que vous travaillez moins en
moins bien en place je suis chose qu'un
année à la même place mais pas avec une
livre en général ça un peu déçu oui ça
descend du lem les moyennes s'abaisser à
ce projet
[Musique]
si c'est parce qu'on me tape 27 sites et
comportant qu'un jeu neige c'était bien
portant que la génèse on est très excité
c'est fort c'est ça oui mais moi c'est
plus embêtant pour moi parce que je suis
resté à la même place
j'étais septième échelon en corse
etienne sur sa lancée le matin en classe
tu as l'impression que vous pourriez
aussi bien que robin
bah oui certainement cool parce que moi
j'ai par contre j'avais dix opérations
les divisions affaire va échanger des
virgules j'ai toujours tout quoi alors
qu'on ait presque aussi bien que moi
même mieux parce que avant j'avais des
divisions défaut des divisions cat et
faussent complètement les relations
commencent à pleuvoir moi parce que on
n'y a là ni vous ni à la montagne ou
mécontents alors on se travaille bien
non nous savaient faire une foire ans
quand on était dans ma ville ont dépêché
pour voir la récolte pendant la
récréation technique là haut on se dit
bon ben c'est pour la peine de se
dépêcher parce que n'importe comment
on sait bien qu'on veut avoir
l'après-midi qu'on va faire du ski tout
ça alors c'est pas la peine de ses
péchés ses compères postés
oui d'autant que robin mois on peut pas
dire que je suis fort en ski mais peut
pas dire que je suis pas non plus parce
que tu es là du chanteur ne me rappelle
plus à droite par là et ben monsieur
quoi sa figure qu'une fois j'ai des
rampes et en voulant protéger des rampes
et permettre que sa fille lui 2 les deux
fois de près leurs projets j'ai bien
tenu sur les stucs on le voit plus
comment au bas ça dépend des fois il y
en avait qui se cassait la figure n'y en
avait qui s'est cassé pot le plus fort
c'est qui on joue
sa peau est plus fort il ya pas plus fed
c'est le champion du seuil actuel
oui c'est ce qu'ils rient ariane peyriac
jean-pierre vous le monétaire dites moi
c'est ce qui profite du ski a bien sûr
ça une fois qu'ils sont ici après ils
veulent plus partir en séjour ils sont
tellement bien il veut plus partir et il
y en a même ou dans des dernières
classes de neige là mêmes qui nous ont
écrit comme ça si la neige est bonne ici
s'il fait toujours soleil il y en a même
qui reviennent à leur niveau patrick et
la maison ça ne manque pas un peu
aujourd'hui la tapa ambiance à
romainville
premièrement aujourd'hui je vais faire
du ski
ça je me souviens toi laurent alors 40
ans 8 je m'ennuie adot t'as pas envie de
voir ta soeur on ignore si les gentils
quand là quand elle écrit par les êtres
les gentils mort quand elle est à la
maison c'est plus pareil
chers tous
papa maman chantal véronique et jénine
depuis le moment où vous m'avez vu
partir de la maison de la mairie ou de
la gare de lyon
je vais vous raconter mon voyage ainsi
que le reste à lagord nous sommes restés
au taux à attendre dans les couloirs
avant d'entrer dans le tronc je ne me
suis pas endormi tôt au contraire mais
enfin j'ai dormi c'est l'essentiel
je me suis réveillé je n'ai pas pu me
rendormir
alors j'ai remonté veut les surprises
des préalpes
on les voyait bien pour la première fois
que je voyais le montage vous savez il
est drôlement beaux hôtels très bien en
mange bien et leurs biens nous avons
descendu de karma déjeuner du café
müller et des tartines à la composent je
vous embrasse tous et je vous souhaite
du beau temps fallon
[Musique]